jetzt gibt es zwei
für die Reportage sind Mittelalter
zum Glück für mich ist nicht so pro Tag
mehrheitlich präsentiert sich der Alltag
friedlich fast all das sind
Handwerkerinnen und buchen
das was wir machen wollen
[Musik]
was fasziniert Mittelalter
aber unsere wir haben ja so Mittelalter
Namen und meiner ist halt Ronson
eigentlich ist das so dass son in
Norwegen der Sohn jemanden ist das heißt
wenn dein Vater Jörg heißt bist du dann
der Jürgen aber bei dem mir das un so
gut geklappt hat vom Namen auch vorher
Ronson bist du aufgrund von dem Hobby
dass du jetzt gar nicht könnte ich den
Bart abhauen also mein Bad habe nicht so
stark natürlich 16 bin habe ich immer im
Bad getragen viele denken boah alle
Wikinger waren bärtig und langhaarig
aber das ist ja gar nicht so also klar
wir können auch nur von Bildmaterial von
ausgehen von Gemälden und so weiter
Überlieferungen wie die Wikinger früher
wirklich aussahen
aber da gab es nicht ein Ja ich sag mal
ein standardisiert das Bild ich meine
heute laufen die Menschen ja auch ganz
bunt rum und das war früher auch schon
so
the run oder eben der
als Wikinger unterwegs auf das Hobby ist
für den Glauben an die nordische
Mythologie hat einfach interessieren
ja so ein bisschen Gaming Streaming
Zimmer und da habe ich so alles das ist
mal ein gutes Beispiel was ich alles
ansammelt
historisch gesehen sagen wir sind Sachen
die man in Büchern findet da kann ich
dir ein gutes Beispiel zu zeigen
da gibt es dann bestimmte Bücher da ist
dann alles aufgelistet mit grabpfunden
das ist zum Beispiel der Messer mir Fund
ist ein sehr bedeutender Fund das ist
eine Kiste in der über 200 Werkstücke
gefunden wurden und da ist auch das
Schloss was Du da in der Kiste siehst
und anhand dieser Funde können wir sagen
so haben die Wikinger gelebt so haben
die ausgesehen wenn du bei uns mit
lagerst musst du natürlich auch eine
richtige Kleidung haben und die haben
wir hier für dich also wenn du magst
kann ich auch direkt meins anziehen dann
siehst du wie es niemals anzieht aber
was bin ich jetzt bin ich in
normale Übungen
das ist sehr bäuerlich sage ich mal ja
ich stelle übrigens Ehren wohlhabende
automata sowie the Ranzen auch wie viel
zieht investierst du in das Leben ich
würde fast sagen so 70 bis 80%
, aber nicht weil ich muss sondern weil
ich es möchte
meine Freundin und ich sind jetzt gerade
in Kroatien Haus am Bauen und da ist der
Plan irgendwie mittelalterlich zu leben
irgendwann so einfach weil wir es mögen
wir mögen das für uns
also wie du merkst wir sind auch ganz
normale Menschen in einem ganz normalen
Haushalt und so weiter
hast du die nicht keine klärt die dem
Kontext
ich habe meine Freundin über tinder
kennengelernt
ganz modern
und sie ist Werte du reagiert dass das
so eine große Teil von dem Leben zuerst
war ich ein bisschen skeptisch ob sie
gefällt weil ich sag mal so wenn du eine
Frau erzählen muss hey ich bau jetzt in
Kroatien ein Haus und dann muss man im
Wald dein Geschäft erledigen gehen ich
glaube die meisten Frauen finden das
halt nicht so geil aber sie ist da auch
echt cool aber ich glaube sonst würden
wir auch gar nicht zusammenpassen
fährt der später Gott für mich ab bis
Mittelalter da ist es ich fahre noch
schneller Weg im Fürstentum
Liechtenstein
jetzt zwei Tage im Flugmodus ohne
und ich duschen ohne Luxus wird alles
historisch parcourtata
vor Ort erwartet mich daran hochkommen
Stress im Mittelalter
ein bisschen stressig weil eigentlich
war geplant dass wir hier unten
lagern können und hat der Bauer aber
gestern überall Gülle verschüttet das
heißt wir können da jetzt unser Zelt
nicht stellen und dann musst du der
Veranstalter jetzt spontan
die Location ändern und jetzt können wir
gucken wie wir den ganzen Mister
hochkriegen
die verschiedene Gruppe aus dem
Mittelalterszene sind raus Lager
aufzubauen ich bin bitte Wikinger und
wikingerin jetzt Gast und zwar
Mitglieder hat
geil
er wie sie sich als Wikinger nennt wie
tut man sich entwickeln
sozusagen
normalerweise geht das viel schneller
aber wenn du zwei drei Stunden alles
hoch fährst
zwar seht ihr alles so sie wie zu
Wikinger zieht
moderner Komfort wurde ich nicht
verzichten
[Musik]
lustig ah das wird dann herstellen
im nachbarlager wird Musik gemacht
[Musik]
wird und nach nordisch oder Mittelalter
tönt
für mich ist faszinierend
[Musik]
das Mittelalter ist ein Hobby ist ja für
manche mag es vielleicht zu sein die die
nur Märkte besuchen aber für uns ist das
eigentlich ja das ist so unser richtiges
Leben das was wir machen wollen
also es ist halt so dass man nicht jede
Woche gekämpft hat wie man sich das
vorstellt die hatten auch gar keine Zeit
dafür stimmt das ist wie heute wenn wir
eine Krieg ziehen wollen brauchen wir
Geld und früher war das so du brauchst
es auch Ressourcen um den Krieg zu
ziehen das heißt du musst das erstmal
Ressourcen erarbeiten und das heißt
dieser Prozess
den versuchen wir so ein bisschen zu
zeigen das ist auch Handwerkskunst war
[Musik]
viereckige ladeband wird das jetzt
dadurch und dann wird es rund
nur als Wikinger sondern auch die High
ist mit der Familie
für das laber jetzt entfernt von der
Gesellschaft vom Alltäglichen
in dem Lager ich finde das unglaubliche
schwieriger
extreme wegwerfgesellschaften also mal
ehrlich ne also klar manche versuchen
irgendwie minimalistisch zu leben oder
zu recyceln aber du siehst bei uns wird
selbst der Kleinste holzscheitel noch
verwendet entweder fürs Feuer um daraus
ein Löffel zu schnitzen oder sonst was
und das versuche ich im Alltag auch so
ein bisschen umzusetzen dass ich vieles
irgendwie noch mal gebrauchen kann oder
reparieren kann umbauen kann egal was es
ist ich habe dich trotzdem Running Gag
da macht Salbe ja genau
für bereits erste Namensvorschlag für
mich wie zum Beispiel Filme Sohn oder
Reportage nach ich sag genauso gesetzt
[Musik]
ich fühle mich noch am ersten Tag schon
gut integriert mich inspiriert das
einfache Leben und der Zusammenhalt in
der Gruppe ich habe Gefühl dass Setting
macht's aus das mit Lied ziemlich gut
kennenlernt
[Musik]
es ist
halbe zwei morgen ich wäre jetzt auf
völlig egal
[Musik]
vom Alltag weg
und zum anderen aber auch das wo man
gewinnt also halt der einzige von der
Natur teilziffer so alte alte
historische Sache und irgendwie auch mit
dem Lappen wo einiges Gefühl gibt
dass man wirklich wie in der Zeit
und ja ganz ohne technische Gerät gerade
für mich übrigens nicht im Blick ist
Handy zum Friseur richten und der Laptop
für speichern vom Film Material aber
dann ist er schon wieder Schluss mit der
jetzt sieht
Schausteller fürs Publikum mit ladeszene
gibt
und umfasst in der Schweiz
und Liechtenstein
es gibt natürlich auch andere Gruppen
die machen mehr Kämpfe das sind keine
Handwerker
das Kämpfen ist sowieso das Bild was die
Menschen eh aus der Zeit im Kopf haben
und dabei war das ja viel mehr und das
wollen wir halt vermitteln Vergangenheit
und wenn ihr am Ende wieder
zurückziehen
hey Leute ich bin fertig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so wie lange die Welt
aber es Schnitt ist fertig gut
[Musik]
das Wochenende
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich nehme zwei Sachen mit unserem
Wochenend mit der Wikinger und
wikingerinnen zum einen wie lang dass
ich die tagak
[Musik]
Gefühlen elektronische Gerät und zum
anderen dass mir Handwerker eben doch
nur Spaß macht ich freue mich aber ob
ich das nur in dem Setting kann habe
will der Aufwand für seines Wochenende
ist enorm mit Aufbau Abbau
Transportorganisation von den
historische Sache aber wie gesagt könnte
dir so mittelalterlich klappen ohne
Kommentar oder ganz mittelalterlich per
Brief du bist Redaktion und vergessen
nicht der Kanal zu abonnieren